various rumors are currently spreading
around James pond 25 with Daniel Craig
one of them is that Oscar winner rami
malek is supposed to be the desired
choice of the Bob Dylan the seemed
extremely unlikely for a long time as
Malik's shooting sketcher for mr.
Barabas final season would have to put a
spoke in the wheel however as the bun
produces a desperate to win over the
highly wounded Moloch a compromise has
been reached according to some
well-connected sources rami malek is
supposed to switch back and forth
between the sets at the moment they are
still in the salary negotiations which
will be anything but cheap for the party
after all the actors market value
increases enormously with this Oscar
with Han Daniel Craig situs James Fonda
should also be - bonkers
one of them is assumed to belong to the
mi6 like want himself while the other
one is connected to the villain and
split by Lupita Nyong'o we'll find out
who will eventually join the cast and
who won't by April since that's the
official shooting start of pond 25 the
plant releases one year later on April
10th 2020 the fact that a second part of
the harbour thriller a quiet place will
be released has been known for quite
some time but now new details about the
cast and the director have been
published if you haven't seen the first
part yet you should skip this part due
to spoiler danger according to reports
John Krasinski who already directed the
first part will probably take the lead
behind the camera again and also in
front of the camera we will see familiar
faces again according to Hollywood
Reporter the two children Millicent
Simmons and Noah tube will definitely
come back the negotiations with Emily
Blunt in the role of the mother are
still in progress the cracks of the
matter is probably her salary
Emily planned to actually cut salaries
in the high single digit millions
demanded only 1 million for the very
successful first part probably mainly
for the sake of her husband and director
John Krasinski nevertheless an agreement
should be reached quickly after all a
quiet place achieved a turnover of over
340 million u.s. dollars with a budget
of just 17 million u.s. dollars the fact
that a quiet place to is meant to be a
sequel to the first part can be clearly
seen in the return of the actress of the
theories like a prequel or a story about
another family are therefore very
unlikely
since the script isn't finished yet
everything else is pure speculation
however we still have to wait a bit
until the cinema release as it's
scheduled for May 14 2020 that a sequel
to Aquaman this plan has already been
mentioned in one of our previous news
episodes now we finally know when
exactly we will be able to see J's Momo
on screen again a u.s. cinema release
for Aquaman 2 is scheduled for December
16 through 2022 which is almost exactly
four years after the first part that
James when returns as a director is also
already known as long as the script is
right according to when there should be
plenty of time for a good script and
there won't be a lack of money either
after all Aquaman has earned almost 1.1
billion u.s. dollars so far contrary to
some rumours MCU blockbuster Black Widow
will not become a r-rated movie at least
that's what Marvel boss Kevin Feige said
in a recent interview so the threat of
the child-friendly MCU films will be
continued to bad many fans will think
after all this would have suited the
background of the X double agent enter
training as a tough KGB hit woman
however you can still look forward to
Scarlett Johansson in the role of
Natasha Romanoff as the story itself is
exciting
with or without heaps of blood according
to some reports Black Widow will be
released next year but there are no
official announcements yet Aquaman will
ania up to Mateen is supposed to take
over the role of Candyman and Jordan
fields new Candyman his predecessor Tony
charge who played this role in the past
three parts won't return to the screen
nevertheless the planned film should be
understood as a sequel to the first part
and should again be located in Chicago's
cabrini-green residential project more
information is not yet known at this
point but we can expect a cinema launch
on June 12 2020 the most important award
ceremony of the year for film fans now
lies behind us for those of you who have
missed it we've prepared the following
overview for you
the Academy's most prestigious and
important award is of course the one for
the best movie a little surprising only
Peter Farrelly is comedy Greenberg
succeeded over his top class cameras
Black Panther & Co rami malek in
himself the best leading actor for his
outstanding role as Freddie Mercury
Bohemian Rhapsody who won against
Christian Bale and Bradley Cooper among
others the female counterpart to him is
Olivia Colman who received the only
Oscar for the film the favorite as Best
Leading Actress out of 10 nominations
the second Oscar for green book went to
Maha Saleh Ali for Best Supporting
Actress for the first time in six years
Disney did not win in the category best
animation film as they had to admit
their defeat against spider-man into a
spy lovers other notable winners a black
panther and Roma with three Oscars each
as well as wise black Huntsman and first
man with one Oscar each
[Music]
you